good morning John right now I'm at Lee
come buddy pre-recorded this along with
all my new Harry Potter poster because
four years ago I wrote a song about
Deathly Hallows the book and how I
wanted it to come out every year since
then I have written another song about
Harry Potter because that was a big deal
for us and we were so lucky to have been
welcomed to the Harry Potter community
and so now I have another song for you
Accio guitar
the Harry Potter I got a lot to say to
you I'll expect you to listen after all
the tubing
me not saying it fee yes I'm saying
a few are the people to enter to knit
overall you get a positive review I hope
that you don't mind I just got one
question for you
well is this it if if the last piece of
the part of part of most of us have been
eating all of our lives is missing is
this one we've been waiting for watches
Daniel Radcliffe valiantly pretends to
fight your war is this it is this it is
this it is this it
dear mr. Potter you did a lot for me you
helped me pick up this guitar and learn
more than
you not buy whole career in actuality
the word bathe and
this would be so I'm hugely in your debt
there's no doubt about that
I'm sorry it seems if I work it off your
back cause is this it is this lack piece
of the pot of colorful students is been
eating all of our lives is this it is
this what we've been waiting for to
watch as Alan Rickman tells us all why
stick your jumbled or is this it is this
it is this it is this
mr. Potter aho the judo my but it turns
out that it's been years since we left
you be high because we're here because
we love it we're not here for you we're
here watch and learn and singing my
videos for youtuber more than any of
that we're to be with our friends
let's clean up the sort of thing that
will
so this side it said it said it you
saying it
today this edit
this place was built to last
we've got more fun and I'll do tube and
we have it I'll pass to save it we don't
want to sing and play gonna love these
books in each other until I die
now I'm a leaky guy I'm actually not
gonna try to talk about leaky con
because for those who aren't here it's
just gonna sell like you're missing out
and for those who are here it's just not
going to capture how awesome it actually
is what I'm gonna talk about is three
cool things one the Harry Potter
Alliance is running two competitions at
the same time one for art and one for
ideas he's gonna learn more about the
contest at imagine better org there are
links in the description first present
both contest receives $1000 in the top
20 get reviewed by an advisory panel
including me and Jason Alexander and
anthony Stewart head and Evanna Lynch
the second awesome thing I want to talk
about is this book the thesis of which I
clearly appropriated for my song just
now it's a collection of amazing
thoughts and reminiscences of the Harry
Potter community it's absolutely
beautiful but if and when you buy it all
of the proceeds from the sale of this
book go to Harry Potter alliances
efforts to increase literacy worldwide
and the final awesome thing here's my
album this is Alan Hardcastle this is
what it looks like and then it goes
again I'm very excited about thank you
folks who have bought it and I'm looking
forward to making my videos with your
script John feel better you're very sick
right now hopefully you'll feel well
enough so that I'll see you on Monday